I'll use my forklift to lift it out
so we can get it to the barn.
What do you think, Sal?
I think...I think...
I think you're the heartiest
helper who has ever
helped anyone with their heart.
Thank you! Thank you! Thank you!
I am Loren Long and I'm
an author and illustrator
for children's picture books.
Hi, I'm Otis.
Otis is a friendly little tractor.
He has a big heart.
We can do this together.
Sometimes he can do it on his own.
Sometimes it takes teamwork.
I can help you.
We'll help too.
He's a tractor who works
hard and plays hard.
And that's a beautiful thing.
Woohoo!
I wrote the first self-titled book
just as a one-off story.
I had no idea that it was something
that would really resonate
and find an audience.
Oooooh!
On Get Rolling with Otis,
they actually created a piece of Otis'
motor that's in the shape of a heart.
An you wouldn't really
notice it until Otis feels.
And so children will see Otis
recognize something, and feel it.
Can I help?
And then compassion comes in,
compassionate action.
Got it!
Otis is not just an observer,
but he's also a doer.
Let's get rolling!
The theme through all of
Get Rolling with Otis
is the unselfishness and the ability
for Otis to feel what it's like
to be one of the animals and
to care for his friends.
Baaa?
Baaa!
The ability to walk in someone else's
shoes is such a great strength and
if we can model empathy
and teach empathy to children,
then I think we can
change the world a little bit.
Empathy is a superpower.
Otis teaches young children that
they can make a difference.
If they just take a moment to
notice somebody else's feelings,
that they can put on their
own brakes, stop and go,
"Oooh. How would I feel
if that happened to me?"
Can you help me?
I could try.
Otis can be the model
that helps our kids learn that
empathy is doable and
empathy is strong and powerful.
Thanks, Otis.
We're so happy to
have friends like you.
I was trying to model the behavior
of goodness and kindness
and caring for others.
To have a part in this television
project, I wanted to make sure
the heart of Otis was in that show.
On our farm, we all help each other.